yeah i knew
i knew brooklyn was different when
uh my guys the wave gang
they they go by the wall now you know
what i mean but they had me
in brownsville projects okay i just
remember brownsville by the way shout
out to mlp
just reading about brownsville as a kid
in double xl yeah they had me in
brownsville
projects and when i got there like when
i went to when i
really seen the projects firsthand
that's when i seen like
this is totally different from harlem
this is no written holloman got nothing
on this
this is different this is like walking
past the police with a bottle of rose
and they don't say [ __ ] like this is
different like they all they care about
is shootouts and they might not even
they might not even walk up they they
gonna call for backup you know
it's just dark over there it's different
yeah it's like it's different bro
yeah i just i just vividly remember
reading billy dan's in a little fame
talking about how they used to shoot
people off
like they used to just oh they're from
the villa they're from brazil
like they were snipers or something
shout outs to mlp i met them too
what do you think is the craziest
neighborhood in all of new york craziest
neighborhood in all of new york and all
of new york
that you've been to man that i've been
to
damn they gonna be mad at me i can't
just say one
yeah now they you know no brownsville is
like the crit to me
in new york nah new york
because see if i say no now it's like
words so we ain't gangsta like that
nah but um i think brownsville honestly
brownsville is different it'll be some
people from east new york that'll tell
you
brownsville for real brownsville
yeah man shout out to mlp yes sir first
family zone you know what i'm saying
yes sir